what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time while
wall street is trying to get rich
the rest of us just trying to get our
lunch money right we're just trying to
be tan we just trying to
live our lives i don't know anything
about all that don't forget block five
is now the sponsor of lunch money that
means you can go earn up to eight point
six percent apy
in an interest bearing account you can
go and you can buy cryptocurrencies on
the crypto exchange or you can take out
a us dollar loan to get your crypto
collateral go to blockfi.com
pomp again blockfy.com
pomp what's up what's up what's up
are you gonna go over the news are you
gonna sing should i sing
no some people would like to hear me
sing you're not one of those come on
come on i'm feeling tall today okay
nasdaq gave coinbase a reference price
of 250
a share ahead of wednesday's planned
direct listing which would value the
cryptocurrency exchange at about
65.3 billion dollars on a fully diluted
basis that's the reference price it
means absolutely nothing
uh the early indication is that it's
going to come out somewhere around
343.50 which would be closer to like 90
billion
uh my guess is that's going to trade up
even from there limit
no that's the early pricing in the order
book so reference price
uh for it's very complicated but the way
to think about it is this is not a
traditional ipo it's a direct listing
and so
nasdaq basically comes up with some sort
of pricing that they think is worth
referencing
uh and they chose 250 right the way that
that gets
determined is uh really complex frankly
makes
not a lot of sense to me but that's how
it's done um
the first number to pay attention to is
that kind of early indication price
uh which is part of the order book and
some of the price discovery so it's not
fully trading
um but that's where it looks like it's
going to price initially uh and so at
343.50 that's around 90 billion dollar
market cap
my guess then is once they open the
floodgates allow people to trade this
thing it will uh pop and we'll see what
uh what happens from there
the next topic is that coinbase has
gifted shares to its full-time
employees over 1700 people have been
given
100 shares each as a way of expressing
the company's gratitude
so if the stock opens at 250
which is the reference price if it opens
at 250 per share the gift means
coinbase full-timers are each getting a
25k bump
in paper wealth look that's really great
that they did that a lot of people
i think uh have a negative connotation
towards coinbase
uh and brian armstrong especially in the
bitcoin community i think that there's a
couple of things that feed into it
one is that they feel like uh coinbase
may not have
uh done as much as they think that they
should have done to support the
ecosystem whatever i think that that's a
pretty uh
lame critique frankly the second thing
is that coinbase always goes down during
times of high
frequency and trading it's a technology
uh
uh issue right like there's so many
people trying to use the thing that it
keeps crashing like yes they're trying
to fix it they they
obviously don't want the exchange to go
down either so again i think that it's
one of these things it's kind of like
the yogi bear
quote nobody goes there because it's too
busy there's a ton of people there
actually
uh and then the the last thing is and
what i do think is probably the
the actual only critique of the platform
uh
that people should uh should you know
kind of have a
argument with is during multiple points
in bitcoin's life cycle
coinbase has chosen to take a side uh in
these kind of controversies or debates
uh so around uh bitcoin cash etc um and
in many of those cases they ended up
being
on the side that did not uh kind of
prevail
now again there was people on both sides
and the market
decided i don't know how much you can uh
kind of hold against
the company or the leadership team uh
but i reason why i say those three
things is because
acts like this where there's no reason
they don't have to give
the employees any shares uh but to go
ahead and give them 25 000
basically a bonus one-time bonus of
shares is uh
is a pretty cool thing to see and i
think it just speaks to the character of
brian and the rest of the team there
uh and you know frankly it's probably
pretty powerful for a lot of the
employees so
uh kudos to them for doing it and if
you're going to critique them
in times where you think they're doing
something wrong you should also be the
first to praise them when they do things
that are good
i think this is a great thing and so uh
all those people who are critiquing them
you know hey give them kudos where uh
where are they
it seems like brian armstrong is very
like aware
of the critiques and i based on this he
um
he said that regulation is one of the
biggest risks when it comes to the
cryptocurrency business and he said
it's right up there with cyber security
and especially now that coinbase is a
public company we're going to
increasingly be having scrutiny about
what we're doing
and people want to understand the
implications of it it
doesn't sound like he's um against
being transparent and communicative
about the risks
no one look he runs a a multi-billion
dollar business right a 900 billion
dollar business like the guy
is obviously uh very very talented he
built an amazing company
um and there are 1700 people who uh
he's responsible for right in terms of
the employee base he's their leader
um and so i think that he takes that
very seriously uh as he should so i i
just think that a lot of the critiques
and stuff it's easy to kind of throw
rocks
um you know at people but uh ultimately
like this is a hard job
uh he built a hundred billion dollar
company everyone chill out so it's
pretty crazy to think about like
coinbase is a decade old it's 10 years
old
yeah not quite started in 2014
i think 2013 or 2014 yeah i think it's
2013 or 2014. so they're getting close
like they're
yeah it's like 89 years or whatever all
right
astranus i don't know how you say
astroness
it is a san francisco-based company with
an alternative approach to providing
internet access from satellites
and it raised 250 million dollars at a
1.4 billion dollar valuation
led by bayley gifford fidelity and black
rock
i love this why because i think that
uh space has now become
uh a prize right and what you get is
when you have
a prize when you have funding available
now all of a sudden what you're going to
get is you're going to get tons and tons
of people
experimenting tons of people putting
shots on gold or trying to build
companies
they all won't be successful in fact
many of them probably will fail because
it's so hard
but what you will do is you'll push the
pace of innovation and you'll get a lot
of progress
and so anybody who shows up and says hey
we understand that everyone is doing
these internet satellites one way
we're going to try it a different way
and they're able to convince what most
people would consider
to be pretty smart investors uh to fund
it that means that it must be pretty
interesting and so i think that just
the more experimentation the more
funding of ideas the more innovation
attempts we can take the more likely it
is that we'll push forward progress
uh and so it's good to see this because
i think space is becoming even more
important
as uh as we start to understand the
importance of the internet
space is certainly attracting a bunch of
entrepreneurs and now
west virginia is trying to do the same
thing
west virginia announced a program called
that was a good transition wasn't it
west virginia announced a program called
ascend wv which will pay people
12 000 and give them a year's worth of
free outdoor recreation
if they move to the mountain state
wow it's not called recreation it's
called recreation whatever
do you know what outdoor recreation is
yeah like hiking and stuff but why would
you need to pay for that
that was just gonna get you there uh my
guess is that what they're doing is
they're basically giving people free
access to like state parks and all that
kind of stuff
um look i think that it's interesting
uh i don't know how many people are uh
twelve thousand dollars plus a year of
free outdoor recreation
on public lands it's public yeah but you
have to pay
and then access to free co-working space
in some of their mountain towns
free access to outdoor gear rentals and
the ability to earn remote work
certifications some like outdoorsy type
of people
some for sure but look this is this goes
back to the whole idea that governments
are going to start competing for
citizens
and that's you can use things like tax
incentives
to try to get them to show up or not
show up or whatever uh but also i think
that what you can start to do is you can
start to do these types of things where
it's not necessarily just manipulating
your tax rate
uh you can also add all these perks like
yeah if you think about it government is
a product
right and so now they realize the
citizens are their customers and when
you have mobility in a workforce because
of remote work
you now have to compete like balaji
shreen of austin's been all over this
for a long time now
and i think that ultimately what you're
going to see is you're going to see the
city level the state level and the
national level but i do want to point
out this is not funded by the government
this is a 25 million
grant by brad d smith and his wife brad
d
smith is a businessman who was the ceo
of intuit from 2008 to 2018.
so he and his wife alice
gave a 25 million dollar grant for this
so what do we think is it gonna be
coming from like private individuals
or the actual government i think it'll
be both right a lot of this stuff
uh it looks like this is mainly coming
from
a private individual but i also think
that you're gonna start to see states do
it as well
right um and so look again incentives
drive the world
uh if you really think about like
there's a new rule that you can write
off
every single one of your food expenses
in 2021
why yes uh well why would they want to
do that because they want to incentivize
people
to go no to go spend money at
restaurants so you can help the
restaurant industry
so if they allow you to write it off get
your taxes right then it helps
restaurants incentives run the world
guys exactly still trying to find an
incentive to get you to put the
dishes in okay um it's ask lunch money
tab
ask lm in the comments below i couldn't
find a good question because
before we do this a lot of questions
pump boys motors
shout out to my dad pump boys pump boys
motors
shout out google it go check them out if
you got a cool car bring it there
they'll fix you up
they'll show you some other cool cars
moist day 96 of commenting
i put the overalls pimp wow i don't
think i was supposed to say that word on
the internet
pomp is leading me on harder than my
ex-girlfriend
did before we started dating it's all
good i'm a patient man my time is going
to come i know it
hashtag moistgate built different
moist i've been busy i got you
do you want his though number no because
i don't want moist out of my phone
who is maybe a serial killer nobody
knows like what
no but i do want his email and i will
email him
today if i don't email you today moist
it's not my fault
it's her fault because she should not
put this
reminding me on me next that's it
that's it all right guys bang
bang wifi.com see ya
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends